well you know everyone's headed back to
the office and now the washington post
reports that means it's time to hop on
the gossip train i love it experts say
gossip can actually bond people at work
and now hot goss is back on people
aren't just in it for the spicy stuff
like who's getting flirty around the big
printer even though i totally know who
is
there's also some real positive sides to
gossip uh people can trade info like how
to handle a tough manager or what to
who to ask for your next raise
i'm sorry i if you want to gossip and
i'm looking and i'm talking to you
please please come do it with me please
it's my favorite thing to do
ross i love knowing everything
i mean
you have an appetite for gossip right i
do you guys want to try something we've
never done before here on the show like
a first uh first we're going to start a
brand new segment called what's the ross
up hey
okay
so these are some stories i'm obsessed
with i want to talk with you all about
did you hear britney spears just sort of
kind of maybe announced that she's
pregnant on instagram did you guys see
that
uh well now all the news sources have
been contacting her for confirmation
i don't have that yet okay
uh but i i mean if she's having a baby
this is i mean she's having this like
whole resurgence in her life it's such a
beautiful time and oh you know she's
having a baby one more time
all right
here's another piece of ross simon
cowell he's the face of agt america's
got talent but now he says he might have
uh botox and filler before but no more
for him really yeah he says he he might
have gone too far oh
maybe
i would never say that he would though
that's what i love about simon cowell
like i used to um
love him on american idol
i just loved the way he just
was dead honest and it sort of was you
felt like it was mean-spirited but then
there was also like a
oh
somebody could address the elephant in
the room
leave it to simon you want one more
piece of hot ross up yeah okay well
this one's not really celebrity based
but
if you've been following me on instagram
at hello ross thanks so much you've seen
uh there's this gray cat that comes into
my new backyard and uh every day i've
been like making friends with this cat
and i named her joy because she brings
me joy
and i just found out that joy is a boy
so
joy boy and i are friends and every day
joy boy comes over and i give him little
treats and guess what i just got belly
cuddles all right so that's breaking hot
ross
i love it i have a boy's name you do
so joy boy bring it on all right next up
we've got some lunch ladies in florida
who absolutely won april fool's day this
year the new york post reports on april
1st they gave a pre-k student their
lunch tray and that had a surprise
easter egg on top now the colorful eggs
look like they might be you know ready
to hatch some candy but then when the
kids open them up they found vegetables
size of broccoli to be exact pumped by
the lunch lady oh i love i had a lunch
lady so nice in high school her name was
judy and she would give me extra tater
tots so hi judy hi i love tater tots the
most underrated potato product i know
that's what i want to do when i find an
easter egg and i love my vegetables
but even i was like oh i would i would
want something different than broccoli
too i might have been with the students
on this one you know if i ever got you a
easter basket i would put little eggs
and i know what i would put in the eggs
for you
can i guess well you don't have to guess
because look what i have for you right
here
here's a little basket
[Applause]
and i wonder if you know what's going to
be inside your little plastic egg is it
macaroni and cheese why don't you open
the egg and look
[Applause]
there's a fork in here
[Applause]
i do know you i do
[Music]
you